tipo un annetto fa andava di moda sosta
roba del the floor islam ci hanno fatto
il gioco ci hanno messo un anno però
l'hanno fatto adesso
[Musica]
questo è il menù è la cosa più bella che
abbia mai visto presume
ma veramente c'è qualcuno che mi ha
chiamato per andare a dormire e the
floor e diventai per la va benissimo è
bellissimo perché non conoscesse il
flori slava ma non hai vissuto
nell'ultimo anno solo conoscere questa
moda di non calpestare il pavimento
perché il pavimento e lava e ci hanno
fatto il è bellissimo è fighissimo come
si fa dove devo andare
devo andare devo andare lì sopra perché
sono tutte le dava ok
devo andare nella mia camera da letto e
bellissimo ci sono pure i mostri
magnificata non devo toccare il
pavimento sono un bambino ma che poi non
sembra un bambino che chi è il mio
personaggio esattamente sembra tutto
meno che un bambino però va bene
sì però non ti casa senta lei che
fàcasino in casa mia guardi che io sono
un bambino che che sa saltare benissimo
da una parte all'altra eccolo letto
dormo mamma sono a letto non vieni
mettermi e coperte non posso dormire
vabbè allora non dormiamo facciamo altre
cose ma ma se può roba lì lo sa anche il
nuovo capito perfetto no occhio
ecco questa non me l'aspettavo cioè in
genere non succede i bambini parlava
play sta facendo ciao a stava giocando a
ottava mentre io gioco club mi sembra
chiaro suonata la campanella e non
diventa lamenta regole di inglese
attenzione questa cosa deve insegnare
che la crocetta il nome del tuo amico
sulla lavagna e chi riceveva più
crocette prendeva la nota e minchia
partivano delle selezioni che manco il
duce danny corina mark angelo cos'è sta
roba qua
jim jam vai entrambe salve c'è gente
online quindi anche on line suo gioco va
bene non ho capito salve ma lei sta
fermo per quale motivo hai un serpente
nello stivale va bene io io dove vado
indichi indichi vado lì va bene vado
subito no vado io prima di lei
e vabbè prato rocca vacca già più grave
ok poi dondolarsi sulle sulle corde ma è
la roba incredibile jump crouch
ok ma geniale insomma come fate uno
stupido fermi tutti benissimo ho fatto
un sacco di pratica quando ero bambino
tutto per giocare a sta roba da me la
cavo anche bene per essere c'è solo un
tutorial dove vorrei dire cioè non so se
è chiaro che da quando ha iniziato a
giocare ancora non so caduta da un
fenomeno
mammamia ed isa c'è una palla canestro
porcava che volevo far canestro è
successo qui aiuto no dice solo andando
giù malissimo
raga sono tornato dentro la scuola
perfetto
siamo di voi nella classe di prima quasi
che è successo che fa che stai facendo
sei contento hai vinto bravissimo ma tu
devi iniziare ogni livello che sta
disegnando qualcosa non so amici dove la
gente
devo riuscire a effetto e vado non ci
arrivo miley miley miley bar code mania
che devo andare sopra il tubo ma va a
cagare va pure sono caduto pure sapendo
cosa devo fare
saltiamo su ste colonne le colonne amen
facciamo un giro completo fischiatissimo
qua perfetto o le due ore per falso giro
a devo saltare sui palloni ok ma anche
la faticosa l'este mani ma perché non
usa le mani ma giuro non ci sono cose
che hai scusami non ho capito non ci
riesco ad ci sono sti cosi da prendere
chi l'aveva capito ok usa a questo
la donna che board è perfetto non so
neanche io come ho fatto a questa parte
ma va bene aiuto c'è un tizio la chanson
du e addirittura uno è fermo ha
commentato la gente si ferma a prender
fiato non ho capito perché li ho
raggiunti e teste di culo come ha fatto
per salire a quello ma basta andare
milano solo ti prego aspetta ma non
posso andare nostra parte aspetta
aspetta questi due waiting wait for me
porca vacca o sei fermo fermo si posso
venire anch'io li come avete fatto voi
da rivali
che schifo non va la pista diversa come
con che fisica
quello era il finale mi sa potrebbe
essere perfetto dovevo uscire dalla
finestra la finestra
puoi stare potete aspettarmi sa come
giocare insieme è più bello invece no
come brian con lui
ecco bravo bisogna fare ciao ciao amico
dove vai
aspetta aspetta mi aspetta l'uomo d'oggi
voleva le linee non sapevo pet aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta ferma ferma
fermati fermati che nike ei new ex plane
to mi
com si arriva la juventus è esperto
mamma mi adesso mi fermo qua
spesso le cui cade io lì perché non era
che tanto sta morendo mi fermo qui il
governo
stop sono una persona autoritaria e stop
your mother is abusi ma va a cagare va
all right baby perfetto tessera e via ho
finito livello sei veramente forte
complimenti hai guadagnato su e nami
swan amico luogo si scemo che senso e
vabbè ma esattamente come funziona sta
roba mia mi sembra che salti uguale a
prima non cambia niente
io non ho mai provato un poco nella mia
vita non lo farò mai perché secondo me
mi ammazzo se ci provo però posso
prendere qualcosa tipo questo esatto
l'hamburger che schifo boenisch succo
posso andare a vedere quindi io lavoro
al cell supermercato però nell'area come
si dice nel non so parlare l'italiano
l'area quella di uffici uffici per ora
la bottiglietta ci può andare nella
sezione bloccata si stima primo check
point e questo ho finalmente un po di
lava mi era mancata
madonna ma che vendono la sta roba qua
bull co sono passato la cassa ha fatto
pip è stato inebriante va bene chi sta
molto costo sempre eccoci al prezzo la
madonna 847 dollari io e questo niente
queste gratis se sta roba la carta
igienica carbo la carabo igienica vai
vai veloce effetto designer o merlin sto
posto ma che è l'acqua ma dio mio
amara carbo fa anche la coca cola
fenomeno dove mi dove vabbè présence
altro per la skill la pura e sola skill
ma no no ok infatti è finito livello che
davano ora che è stato tra uno scaffale
della barilla un altro le santal ok
effetto bene
oh mio dio basta ti prego sono due ore
che con basta definito buono buono buono
mi chiamo caldo qua dentro
sì ma stai calma non ti prego qualche
strano quello nella palestra
hai un tutorial
[Musica]
da noi non voglio vedere come mi fai
tutorial non voglio saperlo sono bravo
comunque a devono ruotare attorno al
comma che casino co demonio aspetta bene
de bellis bravo fermi tutti
più complicato di madonna che bordello
sto gioco sono scarso lo farei comunque
ragazzi questa era porca vacca deplori
slava gave the game
cioè della ottava spero che qualcuno
online fuggì da un'altra volta sahideh
fa l'autunno che sembravo prevedeva eh
eh eh eh
fugatti ci ho messo un'ora io ho fatto
le vado di qua come acer a forks
schifolo dovuto seguire perché pinova vi
è impossibile fermati per il nome di
gesù come come ha fatto impossibile che
schifo vabbè basta lega basta veramente
l'ulcera in cresciuta stato il tipo sono
andato non si sa dove ragazzi basta de
fiori slava
era questo è stato molto figo cioè nel
senso fatto veramente benissimo cost
anche un po titotto euro per saltare su
delle sedie però va bene spero che a
video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi in cosa
che mi piace anche la regia di tiziana
se non siete ancora iscritti e non ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]